actually like down dance I I don't agree
with some of the stuff that he does and
stuff like that but as a human being the
interaction I've had with him he's a
good guy he pays way too much attention
to comments and I think he's you know
he's kind of lost track of what he
really wants you know if he's trying to
find that lashes out but I think deep
down good person just needs some
direction if you if you think about like
top 10 names that are brought up in just
Combat Sports in general he has to be up
there yeah like he's always put himself
into like the what was it the KSI fight
or he's always always staying relevant
now I don't know how he makes money I
know how that works if you're not
competing but he's always relevant there
has to be something to it where it's
like marking wise and so it's getting a
little bit tough for him but we're just
talking about how impressive it is
whether you like it or not how he's
always
always trending